[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un tout nouveau produit qu'annoncé dj
très récemment lors des gi's ne sais pas
si tu connais beaucoup de gens
connaissent effectivement dj hi pour les
drones pour le smau pour plein de
solutions que ce soit pour les
professionnels ou pour les particuliers
mais là des gi's vient d'annoncer un
tout nouveau produit un drone tout
petits drones qui s'appelle le spac et
qui a l'air tout simplement incroyable
[Musique]
alors pour parler un petit petit jet
s'est très rapidement c'est un fabricant
asiatique qui provoque qui je pense un
des leaders dans le drone pour
particuliers qui aussi des solutions
incroyable pour les professionnels est
d'ailleurs en train d'utiliser un dj
altitude parce que moi-même j'utilise
mon film et utilise l'os non plus ce qui
est un excellent produit et qui permet
effectivement d'abord un rendu de
qualité alors dj mag est vraiment
extrêmement connue pour ses drones pour
les qualités de ces drones les vidéos
sont très bien la qualité super hyper
facile à piloter et le rendu est top
et effectivement la dj y va encore plus
loin pour toucher un marché de créateurs
contenu il y avait qu ils cherchent un
produit compact facile et très simple
d'utilisation mais aussi je dirais les
particuliers avec un drone qui est
extrêmement simple et qui va encore plus
loin pour aller conquérir la part le
marché des particuliers
le but si tu veux deux rondes c'est de
capter extrêmement facilement différents
moments sans forcément a besoin de
sortir une télécommande
tu sors ton drôle tu le mets dans ta
main il se met en position et tu as
plein de nouvelles technologies qui sont
vraiment super sympa je t'explique et ça
c'est un drôle que tu peux piloter avec
une télécommande comme ça serait assez
classiquement avec un smartphone partir
d'un ipad un iphone directement sur une
application dédiée
mais tu peux aussi le déplacer avec des
mouvements il a un système de
reconnaissance 3d qui est qui est en
tout cas à l'air d'être bien fait se
produit je n'ai pas essayé tout utile et
pas encore disponibles sur le marché
donc je peux pas exactement dire ce que
ça va donner en faisant son aide mais
connaissant la qualité des produits dits
gi's je pense que ça doit être
extrêmement bien foutu et hx9v vraiment
sympa à prendre en main
tomba le point fort de ce produit c'est
la polyvalence c'est un produit qui peut
être autant destiné aux créateurs
contenu alors on va pas partir sur la
création de contenus je dirais d'extrême
grande qualité où on a cherché des
résolutions 4k où on va chercher notre
but 60 images seconde
là on est 100 de la full hd tous cas le
plus simple en 30 images seconde mais si
on veut créer une vidéo pour envoyer sur
les réseaux sociaux surtout surtout pour
ça on a un produit qui est vraiment
sympa et aussi pour les familles qui
veulent se faire des souvenirs se faire
des photos un petit peu surprenante des
vidéos sympas avec des plans et rien que
ce soit d'un truc sportif que ce soit
juste d'une sortie en famille à la plage
chose comme ça le spark est vraiment
dans cette cible là alors l'intérêt de
ce produit pour moi c'est une nouveauté
c'est un pas de plus comme je te le dis
vers le particulier pour les conquérir
ce marché là et puis pour apposer un peu
plus le drone dans les dents les usages
pour faire des souvenirs
on a connu déjà il ya dix ans l'arrivée
du smartphone qui était une vraie
révolution
les gens ne l'est pas forcément aller à
l'époque en tout cas je frappe le monde
innocent mais à l'époque on n'avait pas
forcément toujours d'appareils photo
numériques sous la main quand on compte
ont été la porte quel endroit on les
avait souvent vacances
mais avec l'arrivée du smartphone
c'était une petite révolution parce que
effectivement les gens n'ont pu prendre
des photos partout tout le temps file et
capter et avec l'explosion des réseaux
sociaux ça a été juste dingue
l'intérêt de ce drone à mon avis va
venir en complément tu vas pas remplacer
un smartphone par contre tu vas pouvoir
aller plus loin dans tes souvenirs et
plus loin dans le fait de capter des
moments on va parler un peu maintenant
des spécifications techniques c'est un
drone qui est léger il fait 300 grammes
il fait 14 cm par 14 cm c'est vraiment
un tout petit truc il ya une vidéo qui a
été publiée par la case in stat et
marquez branly où tu peux effectivement
le voir voir ce drone est le comparer à
la taille d'un smartphone c'est vrai
qu'il est tout petit ce qui est vraiment
pratique ces petits peut le ranger
facilement dans un petit sac tu peux le
mettre dans une poche c'est une grande
poche il est vraiment compact et facile
de prise en main est facile à
transporter
[Musique]
d'autant plus que pour l'utiliser je
dirais facilement t'as pas besoin de
télécommande
je vais t'expliquer ça dans quelques
instants pour l'instant d'un point de
vue spécifications techniques
c'est un produit qui est annoncé avec
une vitesse max de 50 km/heure en mode
sport qui a un temps de vol de 16
minutes max mais sait déjà qu avait
plutôt pas mal pour pouvoir se faire des
bons souvenirs
il a un système de gps pour lui
permettre de reconnaître sa position et
notamment pour les fonctionnalités de
retour à la position initiale
je t'explique c'est dans quelques
instants mais ça c'est vraiment pratique
effectivement pas quand tu perds signal
quant à plus de batterie petite photo ça
peut quand même de sauver la vie et
éviter que tondreau ne tombe dans les
oubliettes en deux saisons c'était vrai
que c'est quand même pas mal
et surtout ce produit il a un système de
reconnaissance 3d et ça c'est vraiment
sympa alors ce système de reconnaissance
3d lui permet de reconnaître
l'environnement reconnaître les objets
reconnaître les personnes les
différencier et du coup il ya plusieurs
fonctionnalités qui ont été développés
par dj appartient cette technologie côté
caméra on annonce un 12 millions de
pixels un capteur 1/2 3 pouce
c est mauvaise une ouverture en effe 2,6
et de la vidéo je te dis on né en 1920
par 1080 pixels en 30 images seconde
donc tu vois bien que c'est un produit
sur lequel on va pas chercher la toque
de la qualité on n'a pas de quatre cas
on va pas chercher à faire des ralentis
d'un pas 30 images seconde
mais un produit ou avoir des images de
bonne qualité
je pense que surtout pour des plantes
c'est que pour l'extérieur donc il ya
forcément une belle lune il faut qu' une
belle luminosité les plans nuit à mon
avis avoir mais en faible luminosité
j'ai bien peur que ce soit pas top mais
c'est effectivement le verra plus tard
si il m'est possible de tester ce
produit une stabilisation sur deux axes
on connaît les stabilisations de dj en
tout cas moi je les connais je peux
utiliser sur le smau s'est extrêmement
bien foutu c'est vraiment très très
stable
d'autant plus que là il ya une
technologie ultra sous certains a priori
la technologie au niveau du software
ce qui fait que tu as vraiment quelque
chose de complètement stabilisé
intérieur paulin le drogue s'est libéré
parce que sinon tu aurais rapidement la
nausée la détection 3d peut se faire
jusqu'à 5 mètres ce qui fait qu ton
drôle quand tu pilotes se soient que la
télécommande il est besoin de détecter
un objet de l'été tétouan il est
distance maximale de 5 mètres ce qui lui
permet quand même de prendre un peu
d'altitude d'avoir un suivi de pouvoir
avoir plein plein de possibilités par
rapport à cette technologie
j'espère faire l'état tout à l'heure et
je t'explique effectivement qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec cette nouvelle
technologie 3d sur saône rhône par
contre si tu veux l'utiliser
je dirais sur un fonctionne et est assez
classique avec la télécommande
tu peux aller jusqu'à deux kilomètres
alors avec l'iphone ou avec une
application ce soit sur android
voyeurisme peu importe
tu oublies les deux kilomètres tu vas
pas y aller taper une portée de 2 km
mais avec la télécommande si tu veux
l'acheter en plus où il n'y a pas qu'à
la fin je te montrerai avait expliqué en
tout cas les différentes possibilités en
termes d'achat y prix tu peux aller
effectivement km est quand même plutôt
pas mal surtout avec un tout petit drone
comme ça côté fonctionnalités il ya
plein de nouveautés je trouve ça
vraiment sympa c'est de çà fait ça peut
faire un peu gadget mais pour les gens
qui veulent pas s'endetter qui veulent
faire de la prise de vue rapide c'est
vraiment sympa ils ont un système déjà
qui s'appelle le faith aware c'est du
décollage rapide tu prends le drone tu
poses dans ta main la caméra face à toi
tu l'actif fatalement avec la caméra et
le système de reconnaissance 3d il va
reconnaître au visage il a décollé qui
va se mettre en vol stationnaire fixé
sur ton visage et après effectivement
d'aller attendre les autres ensuite tu
as un contrôle gestuel aérien ce qui
fait que tu va poser de la main devant
le drone il va reconnaître effectivement
que c'est une main et en déplaçant ta
main comme ça tu vas déplacer le drone
d'en haut ce qui va suivre le mouvement
de la main tu peux le faire monter
tu peux le faire descendre c'est
vraiment super sympa et c'est en ça
effectivement que on n'a pas besoin de
s'endetter on prend la lutte tu vois il
décolle on le déplace tu fais un
un petit mouvement en faisant comme si
tu voulais faire une photo il reconnaît
le mouvement il fait une photo tu prends
ton drôle tout le moins d'altitude tech
des habitués faire un selphy un peu
sympa avec un côté un peu plongeant tu
fais le signe de la photo il fait ta
photo est un rendu dingue
alors effectivement c'est une photo en
2011 pixels sur un appareil comme ça ça
fait un souvenir qui est sympa on va pas
voir les choses extrêmement dingue mais
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
abdou qui est tendue ce qu'elle vaut
qui
la pluie
ro
le ski
go
au final
créée
ça
[Musique]
et surtout il ya un mode de vol
intelligent et ça c'est sympa alors j'ai
expliqué déjà ils ont ce qu'ils
appellent le quit shot alors le clip
choc satin effectivement de faire des
plans d'aspect professionnel à partir
juste de ton drôle tu le lances sur ton
application
tu t'en fait pas et tu vas voir il ya
déjà l'aspect fusée c'est à dire que ton
drone est au dessus de toi
il va prendre de l'altitude et la caméra
va rester orienté sur le sujet ce soit
toi tu sois un objet que ce pour quoi
que ce soit grâce à la reconnaissance 3d
et ça c'est vraiment sympa donc tu
t'imagines avec un bruit qui démarre à
la verticale
c'est à voir des images qui sont
vraiment quand même très très très sympa
et puis tu vas pas trouver partout en
tout cas le système drones ni c'est à
dire tu vas voir en drones qui va
reculer qui va s'élever et qui va garder
un plan fixe sur toi donc c'est pareil à
des effets qui sont extrêmement sympa le
quick shot cercle le drone te reconnais
et il fait un cercle autour de toi quand
m qu'ils s'appellent de spirale alors
c'est un vol aux spirales autour de toi
il va partir comme un peu plus central
et il va s'écarter s'écarter monte de
plus en plus haut et de s'éloigner
davantage ça permet vraiment d'avoir des
cheveux dit dédé plan professionnel mais
sans opérateur 100 personnes qui veulent
piloter juste le logiciel qui va le qui
va le faire parce que le drone connaît
les dires et les opérations à mener
alors ce qu'on continue tu vas avoir ce
qu'ils appellent le taf lie le tac flac
c'est marrant tu vas donner
cliquez sur une zone sur ton écran tu
vas ça va indiquer aux drones l'endroit
où il va aller et lui il va faire la
faire le trajet tout seul comme un grand
d'autant plus qu'il a vraiment une
détection des objets jusqu'à 5 mètres ce
qui fait que s'il arrive qui a un
obstacle au milieu il va contourner et
il va retourner là là où il veut aller
c'est vraiment vraiment bien foutu
l'actif traque l'actif trac c'est pas
mal ça reconnaît jacky mois va toujours
à les obliger les personnes et il va
pouvoir les suivre alors soit en vol
stationnaire a priori de ce que j'en ai
compris aussi en mouvement
parce qu'il permet de faire des plans
super cool et plus d'une fois de plus
sans avoir là
les commandes se retrouvera sans devoir
avoir soit un opérateur sois toi même
qui collectent à télécommande
donc c'est quand même bien foutu alors
ensuite il ya effectivement la solution
logicielle un dj hell go qui permet
d'éditer facilement des vidéos il est
partagé sur les réseaux sociaux
ce logiciel ce qui est sympa si tu veux
c'est qu'il va sélectionner est ce que
lui va reconnaître comme les meilleurs
plans il va les assemblées tu lui dis je
le maître telle musique derrière il
balance la musique s'est fait une vidéo
de 30 secondes et puis tu peux les
balancer sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
plutôt pas mal foutu alors après
attention réseaux sociaux attention à la
musique que tu mais parce que il faut
quand même avoir les droits d'auteur et
ne pas être emmerdés par rapport à ça il
ya des fonctionnalités qui sont aussi
sympa au niveau des photos je te dise à
capteur 12 mégapixels dont tu fais des
photos qui sont quand même relativement
cool je pense comme je te le disais plus
haut du jour on va éviter les clichés
demi parce qu'à mon avis ça va être
ajoutée du bruit grâce à la raillerie
terrible mais en tout cas sur les
extérieurs ils ont un mode panoramique
parler de prendre des photos des
panoramiques horizontaux ou des
panoramiques verticaux il va prendre
plusieurs photos il dans les assemblées
en finale c'est vraiment ça le la terre
et de ce produit comme s'est stabilisée
tu vas voir un truc qui est extrêmement
bien fichu
[Musique]
qu'ils ont un système qui s'appelle le
chalaux focus alors le chalaux focus
apparaît effectivement par le système de
reconnaissance d'objets de faire un
focus sur toi et d'avoir une profondeur
de champ qui va être vraiment minime et
d'avoir ce qu'il fait toi extrêmement
nettes et tout le reste flou on pense
d'ailleurs à photo de l'iphone cette
plus où tu vas te retrouver avec
effectivement ce côté avec cette
profondeur de champ et se joue derrière
c'est vraiment super jolie alors il ya
aussi une fonctionnalité return to aussi
fait que si tu jamais tu perds le signal
comme tout à l'heure si jamais tu as une
batterie qui est faible et que ça risque
de couper c'est emmerdant secrète on
signale soit qu'il clique sur le bouton
return thoune et lui comme il a situé
d'un point de vue gps où était sa
position initiale il parvenir à la
position initiale en suivant le même
trajet donc en évitant les obstacles
ça permettra de mieux récupérer soin de
lui même si effectivement il a 7 ce
problème de perte de signal ou de sable
batterie il va revenir comme un vent
tout seul directement à la maison ça
c'est pas mal ça évite fectivement qui
tombent dans des quêtes à caumont de ses
souhaits
et puis ne plus jamais à part ton drôle
côté couleurs c'est un produit qui est
disponible dans cinq coloris le blanc le
bleu ciel le vert le rouge et le jaune
alors c'est uniquement la coque sur le
dessus on sait pas tout le projet il
surmontera le reste et loire mais ça
permet effectivement d'avoir un côté un
petit peu plus entre guillemets de
personnaliser c'est un produit qui
disponible à partir du 15 juin 2010 est
en livraison que d'ailleurs le
précommander si on le veut dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ça t'intéresse je
t'invite à aller voir la fiche
indirectement sur mon site le cheuvreux
je t'ai fait un petit récapitulatif de
tout ce qu'on a dit là alors c'est un
produit qui est en vente au tarif de 599
pour le plus bazin avec le drone les
hélices la batterie le chargeur le câble
micro usb et puis une bonne du rangement
si tu veux investir un poil plus tu as
ce qu'ils appellent le bundle fly mort
spécialement pour le spark qui à 799
euros actuellement
au lieu de 1000 19 euros alors l'intérêt
si tu veux c'est effectivement manager
tata la radiocommande donc si tu veux
pouvoir allait l'emmener jusqu'à 2 km il
faut cette fameuse télécommande
tu as des hélices donc tu as les
protections des listes de batteries une
station de recharge de batterie et un
sac à bandoulière et après tu as
effectivement la société par une option
le dj el kheir refresh tous permettra
d'avoir de remplacement d'unités par an
ça coûte 69 euros s'être protège aussi
contre les dégâts causés par l'eau dans
nos usages normale à savoir ce que
désire y appelle l' usage normal parce
que c'est un produit qui n'est pas du
tout fait pour les drogués qui qu'il
déconseillait à voler effectivement ton
plus haut il ya des choses comme ça il
est vrai que porte sont fin prêtes à
l'insistance vip avec le dj k refresh
donc voila un petit peu qu'ils qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui sur ce nouveau
projet dj aig qui a l'air très sympa
j'ai hâte de pouvoir l'essayer
dis moi ce que t'en pense aux
commentaires que tu connais bien les
prodigy est ce que ça te tente ce que tu
as déjà cultes et des drones dit jane et
qu'est ce que tu penses de ce produit tu
me dis tout ça et nous on trouve très
très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
je te remercie je dis à bientôt ciao
[Musique]